Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to "Dead End Road"
Now I didn't want to leave it at just that, I wanted to finish this game
And a lot of you guys said that one of the things that I was missing
was that I wasn't buying medication to make the phantoms go away
which was an important mechanic for me to get through this
and get to the end of the goddamn road AND GET MY FUCKING WISH GRANTED!
I don't even remember what my wish was, but I'm gonna get it granted.
If I seem very serious, it's because ... I'm not so shut up.
Hi Grandma! How are you doing?
Okay bye bye bye
Also I got a gamepad this time so I should be much better when I'm going down the roooad
SHUT UP GRANDMA!
Yeah! Oops, shit.
Huh, what the fuck. I'm not doing that!
Stop it!
Stop that!
Stop!
Okay, something's happened horrible
There we go! I got it anyway.
By sheer default, that one really wanted to go
I don't know why
But now we're gonna get on this road and we're gonna get to the end of this.
What do I request of the dark powers?
BIIIIIIG PENIS
"The dark powers have not understood your request" (chuckles)
Well! Let me spell it out for ya!
HUUUUUUGE CORK
What? You got that?
You understood?
I want a HUUUUUUGE CORK, thank you very much
Hi buddy, how are you- HELLO (laughs)
Alrighty then.
(demonic voice) YOU ARE BEYOND THE REACH OF GOD WHILE HERE
Really? Am I now?
Well let me tell you something about myself HMMMMMM
Alright, so I need a candle, a bell, and a book
Candle, a bell, and a book!
Candle, a bell, and a book and a candle a bell and a book
At least I can honk this time, that's nice.
Wait, this sucks!
(pixelated groan)
I didn't mean to do that!
That wasn't me....
I forgot how slow I actually need to take this
because apparently going fast on this road is just suiCIDE.
Euugh
AHH! Who put a baby there?!
(pixelated laughter)
Who put-?
I'm- oh fuck this.
Yeah that ain't gonna work.
Yeah that's what I thought. I'm gonna restart.
That did not go well for me!
Alright, let's try this again.
It's just a sloow slog
WHO PUT BOXES IN THE MIDDLE OF THE GOD DAMN ROAD!?
It's not my fault that this road randomly changes directions like a whippin' tentacle.
A whipping tentacle! You know, whipping back and forth.
Goddammit
EUH
(car noises with mouth)
Not today. Not toda-a-ayy.
here we go BWA-YAM okay we made it
into town and hopefully it's gonna have
a lot of our stuff and I'm not going to
go into that alleyway and get robbed again
Scented candle, dictionary, matches,
probably good
Scented candle. What, what why? EH! I don't know why the controls are all janked up like that
Have I've been fighting that this whole time?
I have no idea... alright, so matches I
imagine eh are what I need to light the
candle that's like a little unknown thing.
Dictionary that's expensive
Blah! Alright fine then
GoodBAHHHYEE
so I don't need anything yet from the
medicinal shop at least I don't think
so I'm not going to worry about that just
now
But what I'm gonna doooo is I'm gonna
keep going and then all I need left
is a bell and then save the rest of my money
for what I need and maybe a repair if I
need it *whispers* I don't know... I'm not 100% sure
AHHH
fuck me
God dammit th...those
that was...that was an
overreaction
that shouldn't have got me that way
aw shit not this again! Someone get the windshield wipers!
oh hello
WOAH hello
what the fuck you can't throw both of those at me at the same time!
I was at a standstill how was I
gonna react if there was no time to go?
not todaayyy
See? I..I can deal with all this other stuff because I can just I..
it's just basically go at a crawl but if a
car comes at me there's like nothing I can do
ahhhh oh noo
oh no its ghost
give me something actually spooky
alright what does the antique store got?
Votive candle?
Collar bell? That'll do
that's a cheap one. BOINK! Ok so I got
matches I got a book and I got a candle
a scented one. What the hell is a votive candle?
oh god I gotta hit no EH okay good
got that got the Bell wait did I get the
Bell?
I think I already had the bell but I
just wanted to make sure I don't want to just leave that to chance
I can't remember because it's random
cycling bullshit thing
ok so this is where things are gonna
get interesting
What I'm gonna do
maybe I can get a pack of cigarettes or
something that will calm this guy's nerves?
I don't know...
*mumbles* definitely not gonna buy scratch cards
Five bucks? Bullshit!
"Reduces stress by a small amount" okay
BUH!
chocolate
what does chocolate do?
alright why not? I'm very stressed
Eh...
ok we're going to see how that does! chocolate and cigarettes!
nothing better?
(demonic voice)
does he? does he want me flambéd?
perhaps broiled, perhaps put on a spit
right through my butt with an apple in
my mouth
that's how a lot of people on the internet would like me
I'm not complaining
Okay! We made it in the next one that
actually was a lot more manageable
I think the soda and the or the chocolate and the other ones but luckily in this place
there's a pharmacy but let me see what's
in here just in case
I mean I don't know if the Bible would
be better than the dictionary
Math textbook how much is the Bible let me
make sure that I don't press...
no
ok let me just go see what all the
stuff is at the pharmacy first and then I'm gonna see
if I need to buy the Bible because this is one more thing til the Dead End Road
so come on baby give me the drugs gimme the drugs!
health check?
is that free?
"Stress reading at dangerously high level" Oh my g-ah-d!
how do I get out of that?
there we go
lets see
diazepam
BAM! Okay
alright so what's my stress level now
doc?
"worryingly high" quaaludes
Oh fully reduces all stress ok BOINK ok I'm good at this as can be aren't I?
AHhh! I'm perfectly sane
(laughs)
Alright! So let me uh
because
there's nothing else to buy and my car is
in great shape I can just make sure and get this Bible just in case you know you
never know with these things
because I gotta bell and I got a Bible
and I got a scented candle (country accent) e'ry thing gonna be good
e'ry thing gonna be good
(normal voice) Alright! let's get out here!
I can't wait for this nice relaxing drive all the way to Dead End Road!
This is gonna be wonderful
and nothing is gonna go wrong and I'm two days from retirement!
not even three! It's going to be good! I'm retiring tomorrow
with my huuuuuuge cork
let me just make sure...yeah, Dead End Road BODOINK
oh man this is gonna be such a good
drive! So far it's not completely insane-o
whew! God damn that was close
I guess I still have to worry about...there's a lot of oncoming traffic and that's not good
I don't much appreciate it
ahhh it's a ghost it's a ghost ahhh
aw jeez
(pixelated honking) AHHH
(crash)
NOO
COME ON
THERE WAS NO WAY TO AVOID THAT! ARE YOU FUCKING KIDDING ME!?
(Mark in shock as he is being burned alive in a car)
ARE YOU FUCKING WITH ME!?
SON OF FUCKING BITCH
THERE WAS NO WAY TO AVOID THAT!
MOTHER FUCKER!
Piece of shit! God dammit! THAT SUCKS!
IT'S NOT MY FAULT!
oh all right...
Wax candle
I'll take it EH
A travel guide? That sounds nice and cheap
Eh...
And fire lighter!
Seven bucks?! (pounds, mark) Fine whatever I don't care it all evens out to about the same price
And now I just need a bell
SON OF A ♫B-I-I-I-I-TCH!!!!♫
I think what I need to do to stay
in the game on that last road is I have
to stay in the middle even if it means
I'm gonna hit a pothole
but I can hit every pothole
Eh, whatever I'll figure it out
What, what the, what is this shit?
What the... FUCK!?
What, what is this shit?
Wh...what?
(pixelated baby cries?)
I CAN'T DO NOTHING ABOUT THAT!
There was nothing I could do! It was a baby in the middle of the road!
I couldn't do anything!
(demonic voice)
It was probably just one of those things where I couldn't avoid it
it's acually a psychological thing and not actually real
I don't know...
Whatever...stupid...
It's stupid! It's dumb!
It's dumb!
Oh god I'm in the demons butt hole now!
well poop me out already geez!
What you got for me? Give me a bell! Give me an antique bell one as old as Grandma
That's a grimoire
Broken Bell?
is it is useful?
It's missing it's clapper, that sounds useless to me...
grimoire?
Sure
Sounds better than what I had before...
I'm not gonna buy a Broken Bell! I don't
know if these even matter!
I'm gonna get it because four bucks just in case but i'll get a better bell later on if I need to
Which I don't know if I need to but I'll get one
I have a funny feeling that I..I I'm
changing up how, woah, I'm changing up how I'm
driving to involve a lot more breaking
because I have a funny feeling this is
woah, the game was meant to be
played
you're supposed to break in response to
you know
threats and not just go 20 miles an hour
down the road because that's a douchey
way of playing and I AIN'T A DOCUHE! Well, I am a dou...HEEEYY!
but I'm a douche that's gonna survive with braking!
like normal drivers do!
In their human cars!
(weird Markiplier sound) Alright, last stop before the end of the road
let's get some Quaaludes!
(falsetto) Yes please!
BOINK!
Cow bell
I like the sound of that!
I love a good cow bell!
(burps)
I wonder if there's anything I can do
for gas...probably not
All things considered, I think I have enough gas to get back but...
Might as well spend my money somehow
Dammit! Not enough cash...
Upgrades?
I can't afford any of this...
How do you get more money?
No wait...
Get out of here
God damn it, how do I...
No
No! Stop it!
WHAT?
N...no!
Wh...what the fuck!?
LET ME LEAVE!
LET ME FUCKING LEAVE!
WHAT THE FUCK!?
AHHH!!!!!!!!!!!
LET ME LEAVE!
LET ME FUCKING LEAVE!
WHAT THE FUCK!?
Oh no!
Come on!
COME ON!
FUCK ME!
WHAT THE FUUCKK!?
I can't leave! IT WON'T LEAVE THIS FUCKING SCREEN!
Because it's been bugged like that since I started playing, I didn't know that it would fucking...
Oh!
oH!
OH!
OH MY GOODNESS GRACIOUS!
All I had to do was alt tab out of it
And hopefully it didn't mess up the recording
but with my good new recording
style, it should be a-okay
I'M PISSED! I'm so mwa-yad! D:<
Oh, I'M SO MAD! >:(
Don't mess with me, I'm mwa-yad!
I needed to take an angry sip of water
Alright, here we go
I'm not gonna go ass crazy on this next road because obviously it's a dangerous road
but here we go!
Try to stay in the middle as best I can!
The problem is that there is no middle line is the, the main deal here
I'm watching
Fuck!
What is that?
What is? WHAATT IS THAT? THAT'S NEW!
Haven't seen that before!
Ok!
Okay, hello! I just saw your show! You did awesome! Good job random dead torso in the middle of the fucking road :D
Fuck, man...
Woof, woof, woof, woof, woof, woof, woof, woof, woof
Fucking! WHAT THE FUCK!?
OH MY GOD! I WANT TO GET OFF OF MR. BONES' WILD RIDE!
Well that's not helpful! Stop throwing
your fucking faces at me!
They're all ugly! All of them! Every one
of them! D:<
(pixelated sounds of a dying bird)
Fucking bird! Okay, that's, I...I needed that. I needed that...
(screams like a man baby) Eh... Jeezums! God
so close!
It's cutting it so close!
Hello!
Oh god, oh god, oh god! Where am I? Where am I? Why can't I...
Fuck man!
Holy shit!
That was like unturnable....oh fuck, where do I go?
(Screams)
Oh jeezums, oh jezzums, I don't like that!
k car
Is it raining blood?
I think it might be starting to rain blood!
I thought I saw drizzle of bluhd
slighty chances, partly cloudy with a stream of BLUHD
AHH!
(screams like a girl again)
Fucking! Don't do that!
(demonic voice)
Fucking... come on now
(more demonic voice)
no not yet
Doing alright so far
Road straightened out... I don't like this!
I don't like it!
Still recording
I'm looking for something to go wrong!
DEAD END ROAD!
(What? What are you saying? Speak boy! Speak!)
(demonic voice)
Well every one of you Legion sons of
bitches can line up to suck my balls cuz I'm about to ♫wiiiiinnnnnn!♫
Any minute now...
I'm just scared to keep going forward
But I-I-I-I-I did it!
I-I-I did it!
I did it!
YES!
did I do... hi Grandma
Hi!
I sure did! It was a son of a bitch and a half
but you know all about that Grandma
"I'm surprised very few make it this far"
I know Grandma but I'm skilled :)
"You poor naive fool"
"Many years ago I too performed the ritual"
(Oh!) "But I was lucky!"
"I was able to bargain for my soul"
"On condition that I continue the curse"
(Ok?) "And lure more unsuspecting lambs"
"Into the waiting arms of my master"
"Judge me not child"
"You would have done the same"
"But enough talk"
"Did you bring the required items?" YES! Do I get my huuuuuuge cork?
"Show me what you have"
I have a lot of stuff...
"I see..."
"An excellent selection you have here"
"Indeed it seems you may still have a chance"
I got the right stuff
(laughs like he's crazy)
"Go now and complete the ritu-elll!"
"There is still a chance to save yourself"
"To save yourself from my master"
Okay thanks Grandma!
Grandma's a little loopy
Oh shit! What do I do?
I don't know what to do!
What am I?
What?
Wh...
What the fuck?
Oh god!
It...it's not moving!
What the fuck?! It's not...
(Mark noises)
Move! You fuck!
Why is it not moving? It's not moving!
What the fuck!?
MOVE!
WHAT ARE YOU DOING!?
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?!
Oh that's right! I gotta hold it down
Oh! You are joking me!
Oh you are FUCKING with me!
FUCK IT!
FUU!!!!!
That is....a load of bullshit
That is a load of...
OHHHH!!!!!!!!
FUCK YOU!
FUCK YOU MAN!
FUUUUCK YOU!
FUCK YOU!
FUCK OFF!
Son of a piece of Beaver fuck
I'm not doing it again!
Okay, that is the end of "Dead End Road"
I'm not doing it again
I got to "an ending" if you want to see
the "real ending" you can play it for yourself
but I'm not going to go through
that again
I've spent way too much time trying to
get to the end of this and I got there
and just because IT was a dill weed doesn't mean that I'm also going to weed dills!
So thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in the next video
BUH BYE!